mais tu as l'air de toujours avoir une
petite race rassurent quelque chose non
c'est bon par mutsch et flipper des
flips et 1
pourquoi c'est ma nature mais ça fait
combien de cartons de maintenant je vais
pas le dire parce que si ça fait 30 ans
qu'on nous deux ans mais non mon contrat
mais il faut se maintenir mais tu tes
bras tout énoncé que c'est compliqué non
non on n'est jamais été installés t'es
pas un scanner tout un canapé à temps
c'est vrai à nomain pourquoi tu encore
la pression on sait tous qu'on
maintienne spectacle là je parle 13e 13e
ce cap elle travaille c'est ta fait des
études de ouf aussi un ouais bah je sais
pas si quand même tu peux nous les
redire j'ai eu le bac plateau j'te dis
le bac
maintenant c'est comme le corona tout
cela n'empêche que j'ai fait sciences po
sciences po et ouais je vais pas faire
de la politique
non pas du tout je devrai bien vu
ministre ment à nos ministres de la
barca ça y est je tousse non
maintenant y'a un mec le sans rigoler
tellement j'étais stressé tout à l'heure
et j'aime manger des chips dans la
caisse manger des chips et l'effet de
lens ohlala non j'y crois parade c'est
des miettes de chips je ne sais pas je
tenais je ne sais pas pourquoi tu
t'habilles plan rouge
si sur scène un petit peu mais c'est
parce que pour changer à un moment faut
évoluer
moi aussi je trouve ça n'aurait moi je
penses tu as raison la clac et
magnifique ménages étaient plus minces
parce que le confinement est passée par
là et j'étais plus mince et on a un
petit pour toucher la fiche aussi benoît
cette vidéo j'ai jamais des anges comme
ça même si je connais mes hanches genoux
et des hanches méditerranéenne mais
j'adore attend ses preuves a été comme
charlie dit à la radio 1
est ce que je t'ai dit à la radio c'est
pas un peu me suis dit un truc en 2011 a
été victime de rumeurs de mort sur
twitter aussi comme bernard montiel oui
une fois ouais moi aussi ça touche que
les grandes vedettes
[Rires]
la beauté c'est moi - cma fier était
petit à l'époque elle s'était mise à
pleurer
oui mais tu vois bien que maman n'est
pas morte maman et la [ __ ] de ces
mêmes attend et vous bernard montiel il
ya plein de gens qui ont fait des fêtes
et des feux d'artifice très soleil avait
dévissé de 30 % game en break était pas
bien anna chaque fois qu'elle me demande
je ne refuse jamais rien avec anne
roumanoff même un bowling
elle sait que je suis vous aviez fait
que tu dîné ensemble non c'est vrai tu
es déjà sorti avec un mec de la
profession n'ont jamais n'ont même pas
si mon mari mais non mais après alors tu
as travaillé qu'auront riquet avec
mishima et ouais tel quel le plus 1 1
non j'aime beaucoup les deux vraiment
non j'aime beaucoup les deux j'aime
beaucoup les je peux donner un conseil
ouais dit toujours michel drucker
oui mais j'aime beaucoup les deux oui
non mais moi aussi j'aime bien les deux
franchement bgg chez ne pas prêter de
préférence pour michel drucker
bah oui pourquoi il faut choisir choisir
ta deux enfants tu aimes tu es deux
enfants on va les mater non mais c'est
vraiment deux personnes qui ont été très
important dans ma carrière les deux
laurent j'ai commencé la radio avec les
en 91 et michel rocard la télévision en
99 donc ça a été déjà parce que
j'entends c'est bon je dirai à michelle
que tu as dis lui puisque michel il nous
regarde tous les jours ouais tous les
jours et jean-michel j'embrasse ces
check it et amis dans le milieu
tu as des animaux dit non je je je je
fais je fais la bise tout linnhoff je
fais la bise aux gens mais même pendant
le corona non non tu peux avoir de gros
problèmes mais ce que je veux dire et je
suis avenante j'aime bien tout le monde
mais après mes vrais amis ils sont pas
dans le vide mais tesco chez des copines
de nia long temps des copains et des
copines où on rigole vraiment à pas des
copies de la présente à jean-michel en
parle d'un cadeau
[Applaudissements]
je sentais qu'il ait besoin de moi pour
qu'on lui présente des gens qui se
déroulera c'est un espèce de prédateur
sur l'eau il a écrit un livre de draguer
tout ça ne concernait alors il était
plutôt soft de swat membres avait il
s'est fait pour les ados etc
mais je les ai vus et quand j'ai lu j'ai
comme vous qui étiez clavier écrit way
fabien de l'être bien sûr qu'on adore
non mais c'est vrai mais camerounais
fait un casting pour une peau et vous
n'avez pas été prise ils ont préféré
prendre un animal
oui c'était la pub au mot il fallait
limiter ainsi gelé bien fait et voilà et
c'est ce qui m'a cela baba o'mômes micro
là est correct dans tes jeunes croyants
te fais plein de pubs et après on a eu
vingt désolé and finalement on a pris
1,5 et une autre fois la même époque
comme quoi il faut bien accroché j'avais
passé un casting pour un film de lelouch
chercher une fille moche
bon je t'ai pas vrai mais j'avais en
plus j'avais mis du coton la voie là
pour ça j'avais passé des essais avec
vincent lindon et après la casting avait
mis à l'écouté et c'était très bien mais
malheureusement tu n'es pas assez moche
on sait qu'un rebelle dans le métier non
vincent lindon joue alors j'étais dans
la même case que david pujadas et jean
françois copé ouais ouais et david vous
êtes resté copains ou pas du tout non
non on n'était pas dans la même classe
en fait on était mécontents et même
année mais on ne se voyait pas j'étais
pas copains bah non on se connaissait
mais enfin on se connaissait pas ça
aurait pu être convaincu pas du tout
hyper sympa bah oui ma jeu là c'est un
mec génial faut un minimum nous arrive
est très beau en vrai
3 min
parce qu'il est très il est beau sportif
libre très beau vrai et c'est un amas
j'adore ça va vraiment j'adore c'est un
super mec motivé j'aime beaucoup
vous aurez bien vus ensemble mais bon
écoute c'est pas grave d'un site
hépatiques et pas de susciter pas dessus
en 2013
tu as fait ton entrée au musée grévin
ouais c'est la consécration
oui c'est avec des enfants et donc oui
oui c'est une statue alors j'avais dit
mais je vous savez là je suis un petit
peu grosse faudrait vous vous
investissiez la statue je veux maigrir
et en fait j'ai jamais maigrir la statue
est toujours plus mince que moi parce
que j'avais un bon négocier pour être un
peu plus mince et puisqu'on peut te
souhaiter en est ce que tu kartonn du
l'a dit depuis 30 ans je sais que tu as
envie de faire ton film est assez simple
c'est quoi l'idée difficile a dit nous
raconter je trouve ça bien c'est
l'histoire d'une femme de 50 ans qui
quitte son mari et qui redevient un peu
ado et qui est surveillé par ces fier en
fait son histoire pas du tout inspiré un
peu inspiré d'autres disent vous avez
des questions pour un art où la liberté
que ces actions on fera face à face
comme ça avec un invité
oui mais non mais justement on a parlé
tout à l'heure du coronavirus c'est vrai
que c'est super compliqué pour la
profession qui se fait quoi de jouer
face à une salle entièrement masqué ou
alors où il ya un siège sur deux est ce
que malgré tout quand même envie d'y
aller j'ai fait c'était trois spectacles
en plein air qu'il était bien aimé le
quatrième dans une salle fermée avec des
gens masqués la salle n'était pas pleine
puisque je me souviens c'était très je
sais pas quand j'arrivais le public
était très content moi j'étais très bien
c'était une ambiance ça m'a rappelé en
fait quand j'avais joué tout de suite
après les attentats ou tout d'un coup il
ya une espèce de ferveur parce que
chaleur olalala vie redémarre enfin
voila j'ai ressenti ça je sais pas si ça
fera ça avant tout les dates mais je
sais pas si ça faisait du bien d'être
ensemble en fait ben si tu devais
choisir entre ton papa et les états à la
halle aux attentes
je choisirai ma maman tu as raison parce
que si elle quitte à trouver au premier
c'est grâce à elle que je fais tout ce
que je fais aujourd'hui c'est pour le
coup il m'a vraiment sorti du ruisseau à
ses vrais nov
oui mais voilà non mais c'est vrai bois
tu sais que dans la vie je t'aime
beaucoup vraiment tu le sais j'ai
échappé en avant de prendre ben et jeudi
je crois qu'il ya un mec que tu es chez
toi que je vais prendre et ida est alors
oui mais ça me ronge potes je vaux qui
se concentre sur la radio elle m'a fait
mais c'est génial c'est super g super
content de base et prend le c'est vrai
nom est un teint d'amour ou mais c'est
elle a rajouté prend le en tout bien
tout honneur parce que c'est pas les
mêmes horaires
puis c'est bien pour lui non mais t'as
d'amour d'annoncé c'est joli c'est
n'aurait pas réagi comme toro y moi j'ai
une petite question pour le sculpteur
elle vous avouer que dans la vienne
était pas forcément toujours très drôle
et c'est je sais pas si con et humoriste
n'est pas un peu une sorte de deux poids
de galère d'être toujours attendu pour
faire rire les gens à dîner et cetera
qu'on nous attendait il est toujours
attendu pour faire rire les gens qui
savent ça doit être souvent on vous
demande d'être attendu comme humoriste
quoi être attendu pour faire rire les
jours faire rire les gens disent qu'on
n'a pas toujours envie de faire rire les
gens mais où vous attend comme ça c'est
l'histoire mais parce qu'en fait de mal
je dîne surtout avec des gens que je
connais ou qui me connaissent donc
qu'ils attendent pas ça me fait chier et
après ça m'arrivait une fois oui dans un
mariage où les gens - rom attendant un
dîner surtout pour payer l'addition aux
pays bas oui ça m'arrange pas oui une
question de madame bouchard question
pratique est ce que vous pourriez
produire son film j'aimerais bien ça
peut te [ __ ]
[Rires]
j'aime beaucoup l'histoire année très
populaire je suis persuadé que ça
marcherait très fort et j'aimerais bien
voilà déjà un producteur mais si elle en
cherche un deuxième avec grand plaisir
je serais ravi parce que je crois bon
reprenons man ka ra titre pratiquement
rien dans sa carrière l'a toujours
cartonné c'est une très grosse bosseuse
anne et ça déjà je sais qu'elle va
bosser à fond et qu'il va faire si le
film je vous le dis je connais annecy le
film et moyens elle n'ira pas elle ira
vraiment quand ce sera parfait et donc
j'ai une grande confiance en elle oui
comme vous croyez beaucoup en moi cyril
moi je veux bien jouer une défi d'ânes
bâtés peut-être aller je viens je viens
de me dire 50 dans les films mais les
filles elles ont 13 ans sont faites très
jeune kelly
si vous jouez dans tes bien sûr je me
désiste de la merci allez une dernière
question bernard montiel oui je voulais
saluer le travail de deux dames qui
durant le qu'on n'est pas sur rfm elle a
fait un truc
une vente aux enchères avec des
personnalités qui ont mais vrai j'ai
hélas je voulais a sonné pour les
soignants personnel soignant et c'est
important qu'elle le fasse et je salue
ce travail là merci je vais d'abord les
lunettes des lunettes de ski
ah ouais une veste de smoking c'est
sympa d'être achetés cher smoking oui
vous les donnez une trousse de toilette
je suis quelqu'un de propre constance
alors voilà oui oui allez une dérogation
allez vas-y prescillia l'expérience la
plus incroyable sur scène sur un
tournage
une bonne question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la non sur scène c'était pas du tout
c'est un métier je joue à l'européen est
en fait j'ai entendu un crac us sur le
plafond et une partie du plafond s'est
effondré et j'ai eu le temps de sauter
dans la salle et les gens croyaient que
c'était une blague et ils disaient qu'on
allait continuer le spectacle dit banon
faut évacuer la salle ont fait vivre ça
peut tomber sur vous aussi c'est le même
plafond
le décor est écroulé de rire non non
mais c'est non mais c'est ça j'aimerais
qu'on se retrouve aux infiltrations
d'eau